jacqueline métivier a appris l'existence
du dispositif habiter mieux de l'anah
l'agencé nationale habitat par
l'entreprise qui a fait ces travaux
d'isolation c'est une aide sur les
projets de rénovation selon les revenus
600 propriétaires en ont bénéficié l'an
dernier en indre et loire
pour jacqueline elle a représenté près
de 15000 euros + environ 600 euros de
factures en moins par an et j'avais une
dépense de 32000 au départ et je me suis
dit je ne pourrais pas bon alors je me
suis dit je vais commencer par la
chaudière et après on verra
j'ai eu droit à 40 % de surmoi totalité
de ravalement et chaudières la chaudière
à condensation et nouvelle génération
connectée à une sonde fixé dehors le
ravalement a compris l'isolation
thermique poser à l'extérieur une mise à
jour énergétique pour avoir plus chaud
l'hiver et plus frais l'été
tout ce qui a été construit avant les
chocs pétroliers des années 70 a été
construit sans objectif particulier de
performance énergétique dont convient
finalement avec ses actions du programme
habiter mieux rattraper cette situation
pour mettre à niveau
ce parc des années 50 60 70 qui a été
construit en masse un ce sont des années
dans lesquels on a beaucoup construit
petite cerise sur le gâteau fiscale 7
verna diène a appris ce matin qu'elle
bénéficiera d'un crédit d'impôt l'an
prochain environ 2000 euros